DR. SAPNA PARIKH: Prescription
painkillers work really well.
In fact, drugs like
oxycodone and hydrocodone
are actually the best when it
comes to medications for pain.
But here's the problem.
They make people feel great,
so naturally they want more.
And also, they don't
just block pain signals.
They impact other parts
of your body, too.
The best painkilling
drugs are called opioids.
Kind of a funny-sounding
word, but they
come from the opium in plants.
Morphine and
codeine, for example,
are naturally-occurring opiates,
but there are synthetics,
as well.
Opium comes from poppies.
Think of The Wizard of Oz.
Remember that scene
where they have
to run through a field
of bright red poppies
to get to Emerald City?
But Toto passes out,
and Dorothy's all,
like, I'm sleepy!
All these opioids work directly
on neurons in your brain.
They latch on to what are
called opioid receptors--
makes sense-- and
there are four types--
the mu, kappa, delta,
and the OFQ/N receptor.
The mu receptor is the one
that most opioid prescription
painkillers work on.
It's that mu-receptor
activation that
blocks the perception
of pain and also causes
the feelings of euphoria.
Honestly, the mechanism of
action isn't fully understood.
But when it comes to pain,
it's believed that opioids bind
to the receptor and block an
enzyme called adenylyl cyclase.
That makes the neuron
less likely to fire
and also affects the
release of neurotransmitters
like dopamine and GABA, which
impact how you perceive pain.
But here's the catch--
the mu receptors aren't
just in the brain.
These opioid receptors
are also on nerves
throughout the central and
peripheral nervous system.
And that's why
these opioid drugs
cause a range of effects,
things like nausea, dry mouth,
pinpoint pupils, itching,
even cough suppression.
That's why there's codeine
in really strong cough syrup.
Because these painkillers,
they don't kill pain.
They activate
receptors everywhere.
For example, the mu
receptors are also
on nerves in the
digestive tract.
Opioids slow things
down, but when
it comes to the digestive tract,
you want to keep things moving.
Opioids cause opioid-induced
constipation, or OIC,
and it's a huge problem.
In fact, after surgery,
doctors usually
prescribe painkillers and stool
softeners at the same time,
because you're
going to need them.
But you don't want to take
these painkillers for too long--
not just because
of constipation,
but because opioids
may literally
change the brain itself.
Using opioids for a
long period of time
causes neuroplastic
changes, or changes
in the brain connections
and pathways, in animals.
And a couple of small studies
in humans found that taking
morphine every day for a month
reduces the amount of grey
matter in multiple
parts of the brain.
Grey matter contains the
main bodies of neurons.
And physically changing
the brain is one thing,
but these painkillers can
also affect brain behavior.
Another example-- normally your
body makes its own painkilling
compounds to soothe itself.
You might know
them as endorphins.
Well, endorphins bind to
those same opioid receptors.
Over time prescription
painkillers
may stop the body from
making endorphins,
because they keep these opioid
receptors constantly activated.
So the body downregulates
the production
of its own endorphins and you
may end up needing opioid drugs
just to be, well, "normal."
And these are just a
few examples of the ways
that opioids affect not just
the brain, but also the body.
These painkillers are pretty
fascinating drugs that really
work when it comes to pain.
But now scientists are trying to
create more targeted drugs that
don't hit receptors
all over the body, that
don't have all the side effects,
and that don't cause addiction.
We're not quite there yet,
but wouldn't that be great?
We can't do Seeker episodes
without our sponsors.
Thanks to Graze for
sponsoring this episode.
Graze makes snacking exciting by
combining wholesome ingredients
with flavors we all
love to create over 100
nutritionist-approved snacks.
Go to graze.com
and enter promote
SEEKER to get a free sampler box
delivered to your home or work.
Did you know that some
people never feel pain, ever?
Find out why and
how in this video.
And what do you think of
these so-called wonder
drug painkillers that are
now the cause of an addiction
epidemic?
Tell us in the comments
section down below.
Don't forget to like
this video and subscribe
for more Seeker every day.